big thumbs down then they went and
brought a case to the u.s supreme court
and they're now trying to stack the deck
against you right now
the last time this was before the court
in a big way was when justice roberts
not exactly a blazing liberal
voted the same as justice ginsburg to
uphold the affordable care act
and this nominee she criticized him
america this is about you it's about
these two girls up here
evelyn and mariah identical twins from
cambridge minnesota honor roll students
star athletes
they play in the softball team one's a
pitcher one's a catcher they also play
basketball
one of them got severe diabetes when she
was very young
does it matter which one the pitcher the
catcher
they both deserve good health care they
get that with one stroke of a pen
one judge can decide if millions of
americans including their family
would lose their insurance one can judge
can decide if millions of americans can
lose their right to keep their kids on
their insurance
until they're 26 years old one judge can
decide
that if seniors prescription drugs which
already are too
high could soar even higher this
is a judgeship that was held by an icon
who voted to protect your health care
ruth bader ginsburg a woman who
never took no for an answer when they
told her
a girl shouldn't go to law school she
graduated first in her class
and when they told her a man should
argue landmark equal protection cases
because maybe they'd have a better
chance of winning
she did it herself and she won she never
gave up
she had her own hashtag well into her
80s the notorious rbg
and her last fervent wish was that a new
president the winner of this election
would pick her replacement when you look
at her
opinions you realize she wasn't just
writing for today she was writing for
tomorrow to the women of america
we have come so far and in the name of
rbg
we should not go backwards as the rabbi
said at justice ginsburg's memorial in
the capital her dissents
her strong words when she would disagree
with the republican appointed justices
her words were never
cries of defeat they were blueprints
for the future so to all americans
this hearing whatever these guys try to
do whatever you hear from me
it will not be a cry of defeat it will
instead
be our blueprint for the future yes
judge
i think this hearing is a sham i think
it shows
real messed up priorities from the
republican party
but i am here to do my job to tell the
truth to all americans we don't
have some clever procedural way to stop
the sham
to stop them from rushing through a
nominee but we have a secret weapon that
they don't have
we have americans who are watching who
work hard every day
believe in our country and the rule of
law whether they are democrats
republicans
are independent they know what this
president
and the republican party are doing right
now is very wrong in fact
74 of americans think we should be
working on a coveted relief package
right now
instead of this let me tell you a
political secret
i doubt that will be a brilliant
cross-examination that's going to change
this judge's trajectory this week
no it is you it is you
calling republican senators and telling
them enough is enough
telling them it is personal telling them
they have their priorities wrong
so do it and it is you voting even when
they try to do
everything to stop you it is you making
your
own blueprint for the future instead of
crying defeat
so do it this isn't donald
trump's country it is yours
this shouldn't be donald trump's judge
it should be yours thank you mr chairman
senator says thank you mr chairman
uh judge barrett welcome uh
congratulations
jesse barrett congratulations um
i just want to say senator klobuchar
said a number of things about kokovid
that i agree with
she cited a bunch of really painful
stories in minnesota and similar stories
could be told from across the country
i even agree with parts of her criticism
of the mismanagement of covid by
washington dc
um i don't know what any of that has to
do with what we're here to do today
huge parts of what we're doing in this
hearing
would be really confusing to 8th graders
if civics classes across the country
tuned into this hearing
and tried to figure out what we're here
to do and they heard as much as they've
heard about 2009
finance committee debates about what
should be in a health care reform
package
i i'm blessed to sit not just on the
judiciary committee uh but also on the
finance committee
and lots of the discussions we've had in
here today fit better in a finance
committee hearing than a judiciary
committee hearing
so i think it would be very useful for
us to pause
and remind ourselves and do some of our
civic duty to eighth graders
uh to help them realize what a president
runs for
what a senator runs for and on the other
hand why judge barrett is sitting before
us today
and what the job is that you're being
evaluated for so if we can back up and
do a little bit of
eighth grade civics i think it would
benefit us and benefit
uh the watching country and especially
watching eighth grade civics classes so
i'd like to
distinguish first between civics and
politics
because there was a time the chairman
said at the beginning of this hearing
there was a time when people that would
be as different as ruth bader ginsburg
and she was a heroic woman that's
absolutely true
and antonin scalia another brilliant
mind and your mentor
people that different could both go
through the senate and get confirmation
votes of 95 or 98 votes
and the chairman said at the beginning
of the hearing he doesn't know what
happened between then
and now i think some of what happened
between then and now
is we decided to forget what civics are
and allow politics to swallow everything
so if i can start i'd like to just
remind us of the distinction between
civics and politics
civics is the stuff we're all supposed
to agree on regardless of our policy
views differences
civics is another way we talk about the
rules of the road
civics 101 is the stuff like congress
rights laws
the executive branch enforces laws
courts
apply them none of that stuff should be
different
if you're a republican or a democrat or
a libertarian or a green party member
this is basic civic civics is the stuff
that all americans should agree on like
religious liberty is essential
people should be able to fire the folks
who write the laws and we can't
the voters can't fire the judges judges
should be impartial
this is just civics 101. politics is
different
politics is the stuff that happens
underneath civic civics is the
overarching stuff
we as americans agree and in common
politics is the subordinate less
important stuff that we differ about
politics is like if i look at my friend
chris coons and i say listen up jack
wagon what you want to do on this
particular finance committee bill
is going to be way too expensive and
might bankrupt our kids or
if chris looks back at me and says
listen up jack wagon you're too much of
a
cheapskate and you're under investing in
the next generation
that's a really important debate that's
a political debate
that's not civics civics is more
important than that
civics doesn't change every 18 to 24
months
because the electoral wins change
because polling changes
i think it's important that we help our
kids understand
that politics is the legitimate stuff we
fight about and civics is the places
where we pull back and say wait a minute
we have things that are in common
and before we fight again about politics
let's reaffirm some of our civics so i'd
like to have
just sort of a basic grammar of civics
for five minutes
one thing that we should all agree on
and two things that we should all
disagree with we should agree on it but
one thing that we
agree about and are in favor of and two
things that we
agree on that we should all reject first
a positive
grand unifying truth about america and
that is religious liberty
religious liberty is the basic idea that
how you worship is
none of the government's business
government can rage
wage wars government can write parking
tickets but government cannot save souls
government's really important war is
important parking tickets are
are important but your soul is something
that the government can't touch
so whether you worship in a mosque or a
synagogue or a church
your faith or your lack of faith is none
of the government's business
it's your business and your families and
your neighbors and all sorts of places
where people break bread together and
argue
but it's not about power it's not about
force it's not about the government
this is the fundamental american belief
religious liberty is one of those five
great freedoms clustered in the first
amendment
religion speech press assembly and
protest these five freedoms that hang
together
that are the basic pre-governmental
rights are sort of civics 101 that we
all agree on well before we ever get to
anything
as relatively inconsequential as tax
policy
so civics should be the stuff we affirm
together and contrary to the belief of
some
activists religious liberty is not an
exception
you don't need the government's
permission to have religious liberty
religious liberty is the default
assumption of our entire system
and because religious liberty is the
fundamental 101 rule
in american life we don't have religious
tests
this committee isn't in the business of
deciding whether the dogma lives too
loudly within someone
this committee isn't in the business of
deciding which religious beliefs are
good and which bullet religious beliefs
are bad
and which religious beliefs are weird
and i just want to say as somebody who's
self-consciously a christian
we got a whole bunch more really weird
beliefs
forgiveness of sins the virgin birth
resurrection from the dead
eternal life there are a whole bunch of
really really crazy ideas
that are a lot weirder than some
catholic mom giving each other advice
about parenting
and yet there are places where this
committee has acted like it's the job of
the committee
to delve into people's religious
communities that's
nuts that's a violation of our basic
civics that's a violation of what all of
us believe together
this is not a republican idea it is not
a democrat idea it's a democrat idea and
a republican idea but more fundamentally
it's an american idea and the good news
is whether you think your religious
beliefs might
be judged wacky by someone else it's
none of the business of this committee
to delve into any of that in this
context because in this committee
and in this congress and in this
constitutional structure
religious liberty is the basic truth and
whatever you
or i or judge barrett believe about god
isn't any of the government's business
we can all believe in that in common we
should all reaffirm that in common
and that should be on display over the
course of the next four days in this
committee
now a couple of terms that all of our
eighth graders should know as things we
should reject in common
and again shared rejection not
republican versus democrat or democrat
versus republican
but a shared american rejection and the
first is this
judicial activism judicial activism is
the idea that judges get to advocate for
or advance policies
even though they don't have to stand for
election before the voters and even
though they have lifetime
tenure judicial activism is the really
bad idea
that tries to convince the american
people to view the judiciary
as a block of progressive votes and
conservative votes
republican justices and democratic
justices
this is the confused idea that the
supreme court is just another arena for
politics
when politicians try to demand that
judicial nominees who are supposed to be
fair and impartial
when they when politicians try to get
judicial nominees
to give their views on cases or to give
their views on policies
to try to get them to pre-commit to
certain outcomes in future court
cases we are politicizing the courts and
that is wrong
that is a violation of our oath to the
constitution
likewise when politicians refuse to give
answers to the pretty
basic question of whether or not they
want to try to change the number of
justices in the court
which is what court packing actually is
when they want to try to change the
outcome of what courts do in the
future by trying to change the size and
competition composition of the court
that is a bad idea that politicizes the
judiciary
and reduces public trust on the other
hand
depoliticizing the court looks a lot
like letting
courts and judges do their jobs and the
congress do
our jobs you don't like the policies in
america great elect different people in
the house and in the senate and in the
presidency
fire the politicians at the next
election but voters don't have the
freedom to fire the judges
therefore we should not view judges and
we should not encourage judges or the
public to view
them as ultimately politicians who hide
behind their robes
the antidote to judicial activism is
originalism
originalism also known as textualism is
basically the old idea from eighth grade
civics that judges don't get to make
laws
judges just apply them an originalist
comes to the court
with a fundamental humility and modesty
about what the job is that they're there
to do
an originalist doesn't think of herself
as a super legislator
whose opinions will be read by angels
from stone tablets in heaven
judicial activism on the other hand is
the bad idea
that judges black robes are just fake
and truthfully they're wearing red or
blue partisan jerseys under there
we should reject all such judges and so
today
when we have a nominee before us we
should be asking her questions
that are not about trying to
predetermine how certain cases will be
judged
and a final term that we should be clear
about i mentioned earlier but i think
it's worth underscoring
is we should underscore what is court
packing court packing is the idea that
we should blow up our shared civics
that we should end the deliberative
structure of the senate by making it
just another majoritarian body
for the purposes of packing the supreme
court
court packing would depend on the
destruction of the full debate here in
the senate
and it is a partisan suicide bombing
that would end the deliberative
structure of the united states senate
and make this job less interesting for
all 100 of us
not for 47 or 53 because it's hard to
get to a supermajority
that tries to protect the american
people from 51 49 49 51 swings all the
time
what blowing up the filibuster would
ultimately do is try to turn the supreme
court into the ultimate
super legislature court packing is not
judicial reform as some of you who wrote
the memo over the weekend got a lot of
media to bite on
court packing is destroying the system
we have now
it is not reforming the system we have
now and anybody who uses that language
the language
that implies filling legitimate
vacancies
is actually just another form of court
packing that's playing the american
people for fools
and the american people actually want a
washington dc
that depoliticizes more decisions not
politicizes more decisions
so judge i'm glad that you're before us
i'm looking forward to hearing your
opening statement
uh later today and i look forward to the
questioning you have to endure over the
next two or three days
even though you probably look forward to
it a little bit less congratulations and
welcome
senator coons thank you mr chairman
judge barrett to you and your family
welcome over the past weeks i've been
flooded with
calls texts emails from delawareans
delawareans who are scared
because they are worried worried about
their own health the health of a parent
or child
because they don't know if it's safe for
their kids to go to school
if their businesses will survive or
because they're wondering
why on earth this senate is focused on
racing forward with a supreme court
nominee but is not willing to take a
vote to provide
needed relief for them and their
families
it is an understandable question when
we're in the midst of a devastating
global pandemic in which more than 210
000
americans have died more than seven
million have been infected and have a
new
pre-existing condition why there were
just three hundred thousand new cases
this week and today more than 25 million
americans are collecting
unemployment this is an ongoing national
emergency and as an exercise in civics
not
politics we in congress should be
working day and night
to deliver them that relief instead my
colleagues are barreling forward with a
confirmation
hearing that's distracting from our
responsibility to our constituents
and threatens to further tear our nation
apart mr chairman as you know
we're just 22 days from an election
there is
no precedent despite my colleagues
lengthy and i think hypocritical lecture
about the
history there is no precedent
in our nation's history for confirming a
supreme court nominee by the senate this
close
to a presidential election in which a
majority of states are already
voting in fact six million americans
have voted
this process flies in the face of the
very rule republicans set
themselves in 2016 when they refused
as a matter of politics not of civics to
it to even
consider a highly qualified nominee
judge merrick garland
nine months before an election simply
because it was
an election year and mr chairman in 2018
you went a step further and said
if an opening on the supreme court came
up in the last year
of president trump's term you would wait
until the next election
and let the voters decide so what
changed
sadly nothing nothing except the fact
that this time
president trump and his allies in the
senate saw a chance
in justice ginsburg's untimely passing
to shift the balance of the supreme
court
for decades to come and that will have
consequences in the real lives of
millions of americans
proceeding with this confirmation today
is wrong
and if i could to my colleague who just
spoke religious liberty i agree
is foundational to our civics and our
republic
and i and my colleagues will focus judge
barrett on your legal writings your
opinions
your articles your speeches as a law
professor and
judge and i think when we do that
we will conclude the ways in which you
may serve as a justice
will do irreparable harm i think
proceeding with this nomination in this
way at this time
will also do harm to what remaining
trust we have in each other to the
senate as a whole
and potentially to the court itself as
if all of this weren't reason enough for
us to delay we're proceeding
despite having two members of this
committee who've contracted
the virus that's why the senate's out of
session today that's why
all of us when not speaking are wearing
masks that's why
the distance between us in light of all
of this in light of the stresses
on our country i think this rushed
hypocritical
partisan process should not proceed
but instead we are so let me try and
help explain to those who've reached out
to me
why and why it matters centrally it's
this
president trump has promised over and
over and over again
that he would repeal the affordable care
act he ran on that promise but despite
his very best efforts
he's failed my republican colleagues
here and in the house
have voted over and over and over to
repeal the affordable care act since it
was passed
a decade ago but thankfully for the
people of our nation
and my state they too have been
unsuccessful
and yet today to make good on this
promise to achieve what they could not
accomplish through the democratic
process they're looking
to the courts in fact to the court
they're looking to this nominee
president trump explicitly promised
anyone he nominated to the supreme court
would
do the right thing and be a vote to
overturn the affordable care act
and just one week after the upcoming
election the supreme court will hear
a case in which the affordable care act
is at issue
and where the supreme court will hear
argument
that supports the trump administration
and the trump's department of justice
position to strike down this landmark
law
so let me be clear just a week after the
upcoming election
the trump administration will be telling
the supreme court to tear down the very
law that provides health care
protections
in the middle of an ongoing pandemic
judge barrett you've publicly criticized
the supreme court's past decisions
upholding the affordable care act and i
think that is appropriately at issue
in the days to come the president knows
this
and it's one reason why he and my
colleagues are rushing to have this
confirmation
just in time to hear the
administration's challenge to the
affordable care act
i don't think this is a coincidence it's
beyond ironic that this administration
which has failed
to respond to this pandemic is rushing
through a judge they believe
will vote to strip away health care
protections today because of the
affordable care act
insurance companies cannot discriminate
against women for being women
they cannot charge more they cannot
treat
pregnancy as a pre-existing condition i
cannot think of a sharper irony
as we consider the legacy of justice
ginsburg who dedicated her life to
fighting
for gender equality it also prevents
insurance companies
from charging any with pre-existing
conditions more
so americans no longer have to worry
about going bankrupt because of an
unexpected illness or accident
don't take my word for it listen to the
voice of kerry who's
behind me to my right kerry from
middletown delaware used to pay
800 a month for junk insurance as she
called it
coverage so skimpy she had to live in
fear of going to the doctor's
office or needing medication because of
the aca she was able to get better
coverage to pay what she can afford
based on
her income she has diabetes she has high
blood pressure
but thanks to the hca she can't be
denied care
or coverage she told me when he spoke
this takes the stress and the worry out
of it
and then asked me how is this even at
issue wasn't that settled
years ago kerry's right she should have
the peace of mind
that you can care for yourself and your
family if you get sick
i've heard so many more stories from
delaware just over my shoulder here
is debbie from newcastle a self-employed
small business owner
who receives her health insurance
through the marketplace
her pre-existing condition requires her
to attend physical therapy and doctor's
appointments multiple times each month
without the aca insurance companies
would have charged her more because of
her condition
and she wouldn't be able to afford her
medical bills and support her small
business
there's barb slater from newark delaware
who was diagnosed with scleroderma
four years ago after losing her
employer-sponsored health insurance
she was able to find new coverage in the
marketplace thanks to the affordable
care act
my inbox and the inbox of all my
colleagues are filled with stories like
carries debbie's barbs
and they highlight the breadth of what
the aca means to the american people
the ability of young people to stay in
their families insurance lower
out-of-pocket costs for seniors
prescriptions
the elimination of lifetime caps these
protections are
on the line in the ballot and on the
docket
of the supreme court and it's not just
the aca at risk
judge i'm i'm deeply concerned about
ways in which
your approach to something that may
sound abstract
to folks watching scary decisis or
precedent
that means your approach to reviewing
and reconsidering
and possibly overturning long-settled
cases
may overturn some of the very principles
for which justice ginsburg fought her
entire adult life principles that
protect
settled fundamental rights for all
americans
what might this mean cases like griswold
versus connecticut
that established married couples have a
right to obtain and use contraception in
the privacy of your own home
may be in danger of being struck down
it means cases like roe versus wade
which protects a woman's right
to make her own critical health care
decisions
may be on the line and it means
obergefell versus hodges
which made marriage equality the law of
this land could be overruled
just a day after we celebrated coming
out day nationally
stripping lgbtq individuals of what
justice kennedy
memorably called equal dignity in the
eyes of the law
this is what i believe is at stake with
this nomination
judge barrett you will be deciding cases
that have real
daily impacts on the lives of millions
of americans
they deserve to understand why president
trump nominated you
and what consequences your decisions may
have on them
and their lives i've heard my republican
colleagues say all they care about is
finding a future justice
who will apply the law as written as if
all this is about today is an
abstract fight about interpretive
methodology and jurisprudence
they seem shocked we're talking about
what the supreme court
might do if judge barrett were to become
justice spirit
but judge barrett i'm not suggesting you
made some secret deal with president
trump
but i believe the reason you were chosen
is precisely because your judicial
philosophy
as repeatedly stated could lead to the
outcomes president trump
has sought and i think that has dramatic
and potentially very harmful
consequences with regards to the
election
the affordable care act and long-settled
rights
this is what i intend to lay out this
week and this is what i hope the
american people will hear
in the course of this confirmation here
thank you mr chairman thanks
uh for planning purposes i think i
talked to senator feinstein
uh we will go to senator hawley
blumenthal
and tillis we'll take a 30-minute break
to grab a bite to eat and take a little
bit of a break and come back and finish
up
so uh senator holly
thank you mr chairman judge barrett
welcome it's good to see you again
jesse barrett welcome and to you and
your family as well
i see that some of your children are
getting a break they've earned it i
think
i'm amazed as i've been watching uh i've
got two little boys at home my wife and
i do
i can't believe how uh calmly uh your
children have been sitting for a couple
of hours so maybe you can give me some
tips
uh jesse and judge when we're finished
here you know we've gotten to read a lot
about
your family in the last few weeks we've
gotten to read a lot about you and
in the press and in particular about
your religious beliefs
one attack after another in the liberal
media one hit piece
after another many of them echoed by
members of this committee like
this one for instance barrett long
active with insular
christian group we've read we've read
stories about your catholic lifestyle
stories about how you raise your
children stories about how you adopted
your children stories about your
catholic doctrinal
beliefs over and over and over
questioning whether you have i guess the
independence
to be a judge a justice on the united
states supreme court and it's not just
in the newspapers it's members of this
committee
including the democratic nominee for
vice president of the united states
who has questioned past nominees who've
come before this committee about their
membership in catholic fraternal
organizations like the knights of
columbus
and for those watching at home that's
right you heard me correctly senator
harris and others on this committee have
repeatedly questioned
judicial nominees fitness for office
because of their membership in the
knights of columbus
the ranking member when you were last
before this committee judge for your
initial confirmation hearings the
ranking member
referred to your catholic convictions as
dogma that's a quote
that lives loudly within you picking up
the very terminology of anti-catholic
bigotry
current in this country a century ago
she wasn't alone
other senators on this committee last
time asked you if you were an
orthodox catholic one senator said she
worried that you would be a catholic
judge if you were confirmed because of
your religious beliefs i guess as
opposed to
an american judge as if you can't be
both a devout catholic
and a loyal american citizen and it's
not just you judge
other nominees who have come from before
this committee for years now have been
asked by my democrat colleagues over and
over their views on
sin their views on the afterlife their
views and about their membership
statements of catholic
organizations about their membership and
other christian organizations and on
and on and on and let's be clear about
what this is
this is an attempt to broach a new
frontier
to set up a new standard actually it's
an attempt to bring back an
old standard that the constitution of
the united states explicitly
forbids i'm talking about a religious
test
for office article six of the
constitution of the united states before
we even get to the bill of rights
article six of the constitution of the
united states says clearly
and i quote no religious test shall ever
be required as a qualification to
any office or public trust under the
united states
now that was big news in 1787 when it
was written and it's worth
remembering why it's because no
country no republic in the history of
the world
had ever guaranteed to its citizens the
right to freedom of conscience
and religious liberty every other
country that had ever
existed tied together the religious
beliefs that would be approved by the
powerful
and the right to serve in office or to
vote or just to be
a citizen in every other country across
history
you had to agree with what those in
power agreed with
in order to hold office or be a citizen
in good standing you had to sign a
particular
religious confession or you had to
disavow a particular religious group
swear not to follow the pope for
instance you had to pledge allegiance
to the god of the city or the god of the
empire
this was true from 18th century britain
all the way back to ancient rome
and so when our founders put article six
into the constitution united states they
were making a very
deliberate choice they were breaking
with all of that past history and they
were saying in america
it would be different in the united
states of america we would not allow the
ruling class to have veto power over
your faith over what americans believed
over who we gathered with to worship and
why and where and how
no in this country the people of the
united states
would be free to follow their own
religious
convictions free to worship free to
exercise their religion
and people of faith would be welcome in
the public sphere
they'd be welcome there they'd be
welcomed without having to get the
approval of those in power like those on
this committee they would be
welcome to come and to bring their
religious beliefs to bear
on their lives on their office and all
that they do
so long of course as they were peaceful
citizens who followed the law
religious people of all backgrounds
would be welcome
in public life and no person in power
would be able to control what the
american people
any american citizen thought or believed
or who
they worshipped this freedom of
conscience and religious liberty
undergirds all of our other rights
because it tells the government that it
cannot tell us what to think
or who we can assemble with or how we
can worship
or what we can say and that's why
article six is there even before we get
to the bill of rights and the first
amendment but this
bedrock principle of american liberty
is now under attack that is what it
is at stake when we read these stories
attacking
judge barrett for her faith that is what
is at stake when my democratic
colleagues repeatedly questioned judge
barrett and many other judicial nominees
about their religious beliefs about
their religious membership about their
religious practices about their
family beliefs and practices that is an
attempt
to bring back the days of the religious
test
that is an attempt to bring back the
veto power
of the powerful over the religious
beliefs
and sincerely held convictions of the
american people and that is what is
at stake in this confirmation hearing
judge barrett is a catholic we all know
that
she's a devout catholic we all know that
she and her husband have chosen to raise
their family according to their catholic
beliefs
and faithful fellowship with other
catholics we all know that
heck 65 million americans are catholics
and many many millions
many many millions more are christians
of other persuasions
are they to be told that they cannot
serve in public office
that they are not welcome in the public
sphere unless the members of this
committee sign off on their religious
beliefs
i for one do not want to live in such an
america and the constitution of the
united states
flatly prohibits it now the constitution
says
the people of faith like judge barrett
are welcome in high office
welcome in any office welcome throughout
our public life here in this country and
i would just say to my democrat
colleagues
that these years now this pattern in
practice as we say in the law
this pattern and practice of religious
bigotry
because that's what it is when you tell
somebody that they're too catholic to be
on the bench
when you tell them they're going to be a
catholic judge not an american judge
that's bigotry
the pattern and practice of bigotry from
members of this committee
must stop and i would expect
that it be renounced now i just heard
my colleague senator coons make a
reference to an old case
the griswold case which i can only
assume
is another hit at judge barrett's
religious faith referring to catholic
doctrinal
beliefs i don't know what else it could
be since no one has challenged this case
it's not a live issue and hasn't been
for decades this
is the kind of thing i'm talking about
and this is the sort of attacks
that must stop i look forward judge
barrett
to getting to the chance to speak with
you further about your
legal credentials about your legal views
about your approach to the law and your
judicial philosophy
but i hope that one thing that this
confirmation process will stand for in
the end i hope when we look back
at the confirmation hearings for judge
amy barrett soon i hope to be justice
amy barrett one thing we will say is
that was the time
that was the year that the attempt to
bring back religious tests for office
was finally stopped thank you mr
chairman
sir blumenthal
thank you mr chairman uh judge barrett
and to your family
welcome to the committee i want to
introduce you to one of my constituents
connor curran of ridgefield connecticut
he
is 10 years old and he suffers from
duchene muscular dystrophy
it is a horrible incurable
disease it slowly deprives children of
the strength and their ability to move
eventually it robs them of their lives
the costs of providing connor's care
are astronomical but for conor and his
family
it is worth every penny
conor is a superhero but he's always had
a real sidekick
he's had the protection of the
affordable care act
it has shielded him and his family
from arbitrary caps on coverage that
would have cut off his care
when it became too expensive it has
protected
conor from losing insurance because
of this insidious disease that he
never caused and
chose the affordable care act
has given his family a measure of relief
of hope of peace they
still worry about conor's health but not
their coverage
or its costs conor
and millions of others like him are why
i will oppose
your nomination your nomination is about
the republican goal of repealing the
affordable care act the obamacare
they seem to detest so much
it's about people like conor protections
for people
with pre-existing conditions tax credits
that make health insurance more
affordable bans on
charging women more simply because they
are women
that's what my republican colleagues
have been finding to repeal for
the last decade they voted dozens and
dozens of times to repeal
the affordable care act and they have
challenged it
twice unsuccessfully in the united
states supreme court
and each time they failed
but now just one week after the election
as you know the fate of the affordable
care act will
be again in the hands of the united
states
supreme court republicans have turned
again to the court
to try to achieve judicially what they
cannot
achieve legislatively
president trump has vowed that any judge
he nominated would pass
the very strong test his words
and that they would strike down the
affordable care act
judge barrett in all honesty you have
auditioned for this job
through your academic writing and
judicial opinions and you've passed
that test in fact
you've stated twice in effect that you
would have voted to strike down
the affordable care act had you been a
justice
at the time you've been vetted you've
been screened
by the trump administration and special
interests who want
an activist judge they want someone who
will legislate from the bench
and strike down laws supported by
a vast majority of the american people
and that activism uses originalism
as a smokescreen if the american people
have
any doubts about how dedicated my
republican colleagues are
to taking away people's health care
just listen to their own words
they've been remarkably candid
and forthright senator graham
our chairman has said you can't repair
this monstrosity i'm quoting
you can't repair this monstrosity called
obamacare
you have to tear it down and start over
senator ernst has said quote i support
immediate action to repeal obamacare and
replace it
senator cornyn it's time to repeal
and replace senator tillis repeal
obamacare let's end this disaster
and president trump himself has said
we want to terminate obamacare
millions of americans more than 130
million
have a pre-existing condition asthma
heart disease diabetes cancer
parkinson's
pregnancy and now by the cruelest of
ironies
covet 19 covet 19 the cause of this
pandemic
now is a pre-existing condition
that could prevent millions of americans
from being covered by
health care stripping health care from
millions of americans during
a pandemic that's really what is at
stake
in the republican lawsuit now before the
supreme court and in this nomination
and sadly it's not just the affordable
care act that's at stake
it's a woman's right to decide when
and how to have a family control over
her own
body an activist judge on the bench
doing what congress could not do would
also
strike down common sense gun safety laws
connecticut has been at the forefront on
gun violence
protection on gun safety
judge you acknowledged that your
dissenting opinion in canner
sounds kind of draco
that's because it is but if your views
on the second amendment
are adopted by the kinetic by the
supreme court
it would imperil common sense state laws
like connecticut's all around the
country
today we ought to be working on
improving american health care we ought
to be fighting
covet 19 which has infected 8 million
americans and
killed more than 215 thousand we should
be producing a national
testing strategy instituting effective
contact raising
and securing sufficient ppe we ought to
be providing
assistance to the millions of americans
who have lost their job
and face economic hardship and
heartbreak
president trump has failed to do any of
it instead
he and our republican colleagues are
riveted on
rushing a judge through this sham
process
dropping everything else presidents
trump
failure to act will likely lead
to 55 000 additional
deaths 55 000 additional
americans laws over just the next
three months senate republicans
are refusing to address american health
care or covet 19 or economic relief
because they care more about putting an
extremist ideological
judge on the bench and not just
on the supreme court i've learned as a
senator
that there are very few unwritten rules
very few written rules i should say
in this place but there is one very
important
unwritten rule keep your word
republicans have all sorts of excuses
for why they are breaking their promise
the promise that they would not
confirm a supreme court justice during
an election year
each excuse boils down to nothing more
than
raw political power they're doing it
because they can
but mike does not make right
they have boasted they have the votes
but they
don't have the american people and they
don't have history on
their side the american people want
a plan to fight and conquer
this disease they want a plan to put
americans
back to work they want a blueprint for
the future
not rolling back rights and turning back
the clock i revere
the supreme court i clerk for justice
harry blackman i've argued
cases before the court four times
now i'm really deeply concerned that the
supreme court is losing the trust
and respect of the american people
the authority of the supreme court
depends on that trust
it has no army or police force to
enforce
its decisions
the american people follow the supreme
court's commands
even when they disagree because they
respect
its authority and now
president trump and the republican
setter are
eroding indeed destroying that
legitimacy
they've stripped the american people of
their say
in this process simply to confirm a
justice who will
strike down in court legislate from the
bench
what they can't repeal in congress
your participation let me be very blunt
in any case involving donald trump's
election would immediately do explosive
enduring harm to the court's legitimacy
and
to your own credibility you must
recuse yourself the american people are
afraid
and they're angry and for good reason
it's a break the glass moment americans
must use their voices to
speak out and stand up to contact my
colleagues on this committee
despite their boasts about having the
votes
stand up and speak out to protect their
own health
public health and the health of our
democracy
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
blumenthal uh we will now
uh have senator tillis who's with us
remotely
after his uh opening statement we'll
come back at 12
20 and senator hirono you will be the
first one
to make a statement so senator tillis
thank you chairman graham and ranking
member feinstein
i want to take a moment to honor the
life and legacy of justice ginsburg
she was a living legend and a giant in
the legal world
as a professor as a lawyer and as a
judge and a justice
she's an inspirational model and role
model
and to honor her legacy and i just want
to make sure that her family knows the
nation
more into their lives but today we're
here to consider the nomination of a
highly qualified judge to the united
states supreme court
judge amy tony barrett she's the top
legal scholar a professor in the mold of
the late justice scalia
the work is widely respected in the
legal community and it's clear why
former students voted for multiple times
to be the distinguished professor of the
year at the notre dame
law school it's also why every full-time
faculty member of notre dame law
supports her nomination the legal work
and teaching have inspired hundreds of
young lawyers
especially aspiring female lawyers she's
a remarkable mother she has seven
beautiful children and in spite of being
busy working as the seventh circuit of
justice she makes henry involved in his
community
and this nomination is important because
it's going to have a lasting impact on
all the public
adjusted service on the bench involved
every important issue facing our
constitutional republic
what are the limits of abusive and
inclusive government power what's the
problem all of these standards of
government
and what are the fundamental protections
that our constitution goes to all
americans these are foundational
questions to the supreme court and they
consider them every single term
if confirmed hudson will be tasked with
answering these questions and i believe
she's going to do a great job
but it's not like designing the
constitution that's most important
it's disgusting the document itself that
includes our freedom
justice scalia understood this he is
fond of saying
every dictator in the world every
president for life has a bill of rights
that's not what makes us good what makes
us clear is our constitution
think of the word constitution it means
structure
justice stories went on to note the
genius of our founding generation
is that it displays power across
multiple departments
the yellow danger to a constitutional
republic is centralization of power
and any one part of government when that
happens
liberty dies and tyranny lanes that's
why it's critical that supreme court
justice maintain the property law
they decide cases they don't make policy
in recent decades the court is different
towards the pen where it decides
majority disputes
over policy rather than deserving those
decisions to the american people
to acting to their elected
representatives people like those of us
in the u.s senate
article 3 judges cannot and should not
be policymakers
we've heard many speak today about
policy priorities that they'd like and
ask this court to pass
engaged and describe judgement's
nomination as an end of healthcare
abortion rights labor rights and the
list goes
on and on and on these statements are
unfair and unclear
this week they'll attempt to have judge
barrett commit the policy outcomes
rather than do the work
for that policy outcome in the u.s
senate
just last month while they were falsely
claiming judges nomination
dnn into the productions for two
existing conditions
every single democrat on this committee
voted against the measure that to do
just that
they're failing to do their jobs and
they want the court to do it for them
now the deal judge does yes not only one
of the most qualified individuals
to be nominated but she also understands
the probable law of the article through
black
she reaches conclusions dictated by the
law
not by personal preference that's the
right thing to do
my democratic plan is by the idea a
nominee has pre-determined outcomes
in mind while in the same year
they demand the nominee against the
third outcome of a case
the is incredible there is no essential
facts
judgmental dealings aren't meant to do
more against a particular policy outcome
she's not a legislator that's our job
however
when the minority can't get a bad policy
test in congress
they turned to the courts to demand that
judges entered the law
not as written but it stood before it
but can you simply order the outcome the
law dictates
it's passed by congress a politically
accountable brand
nothing more and nothing less my
democratic colleagues claim they care
about the first amendment the fifth
amendment the 14th amendment
if they care about our constitutional
liberties submissions care about
confirming the judge who understands the
proper law of the supreme court
right there by none can justify the end
up by none
the quite justice influence real thing
enduring things happens one step at a
time
it doesn't happen by judicial fiance
judge barrett understands that principle
she knows the role of supreme court
justice and she is highly qualified to
do this job
judge that when i met with you in the
capitol
i asked you to sign two pocket
constitutions to my two granddaughters
and in it you go to the same day when
they're old enough to understand the
significance
i'm going to explain to them that just
like justice barrett
they can with hard work and
determination utilize their american
dream
so for the next few days when members of
this committee mischaracterize the views
their allies in the liberal media are
saying terrible things about you and
your family
stand tall stand proud and stand true
rely on your safe i know this is an
inspiration to millions of young women
in this country like my granddaughters
and yet proud of you
thank you judge barrett for being with
us today congratulations
on the recognition of your hard work and
your character
i look forward to hearing your testimony
thank you mr chairman
thank you antenna uh
so
oh yeah
you